يظهر هذا الفيديو الذي نشرته على الانترنت
منظمه هنغاو غير الحكوميه لحقوق الانسان
قوات الامن تطلق الذخيره الحيه على
المتظاهرين في مدينه جوان رود الكرديه غرب
ايران
على بعد اميال قليله لا تتوقف المظاهرات
في بلده رفن سار هذه المنطقه التي يقطمها
الاكراد كان رد فعل السلطات على
احتجاجاتها قاتلا في كثير من الاحيان بحسب
الامم المتحده
في مدن تقتنها اغلبيه كرديه في الاسبوع
الماضي تلاقينا تقارير عن رد فعل عنيف
للقوات الامن على الاحتجاجات في العديد من
المدن ذات الاغلبيه الكرديه بما في ذلك
9 لايك باريس سيتي انتشرت الاحتجاجات في
جميع انحاء ايران على اثر وفاه الشابه
الكرديه مساء 22 عاما بعد حجزها من قبل
شرطه الاخلاق في السادس عشر سبتمبر لعدم
التزامها قواعد اللباس الصارمه كما قالت
الشرطه جلسه خاصه بمجلس حقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده تعقد هذا الخميس في جنيف
لمناقشه الوضع في ايران
وكرامه وحقوق بدلا من استخدام القوه غير
المجديه وغير المناسبه لقمع الاحتجاجات
احتجاجات تردد صداها في ملاعب قطر
المجاوره ضمن نهائيات كاس العالم لكن
النظام الايراني
مع المتظاهرين متهم عناصر اجنبيه باثاره
الاحتجاجات لزعزعه الاستقرار